[Musique]
travailleuses travailleurs
nous allons entendre des promesses et
des mensonges de la part des grands
candidats il n'y en aura pour les femmes
pour les jeunes pour les vieux pour les
petits commerçants pour les agriculteurs
il vous le faire parce qu'ils ont besoin
de nos voix pour être élu moi je ne me
présente pas pour faire carrière pour
être président de la république ni même
ministre dans un quelconque gouvernement
je me présente pour dire en tant que
femme du peuple qu'ils mentent tous
quand il parle des femmes ont bien sûr
ils ont créé un ministère de la
condition féminine
mais qu'est ce que cela a changé dans la
vie de millions de femmes
on a voté une nouvelle loi sur l'égalité
des salaires masculins et féminins et
ses lois continuent à ne pas être
appliquée comme c'est le cas le plus
souvent quand il s'agit de loi favorable
au pop
il n'y a personne pour les appliquer ou
pour les faire appliquer alors les
femmes continuent à être sous payés sous
qualifiés et les femmes du pop continue
à avoir des problèmes d'argent tous les
jours
plus encore qu'elle soit au travail
qu'elle soit à la maison elle continue à
être considérées comme des citoyennes de
seconde zone
pourquoi cela pourquoi cette inégalité
dans les fêtes et dans les mentalités
parce que la femme serait inférieure à
l'homme - capable moins résistante moins
intelligente mais tous les jours on peut
vérifier le contraire la société ne
tient debout que parce que des millions
de femmes remplissent modestement
obscurément avec un dévouement sans
limite les tâches de ménagère
d'éducatrice d'intendance et pour près
de la moitié d'entre elles ces tâches
s'ajoute à leur travail social car elles
sont aussi os vendeuse infirmières
employés elle cultive la terre soigne
les animaux tiennent boutique sans les
femmes sans leur travail salarié sans
leur travail gratuit la société actuelle
s'effondrerait elle ne saurait pas moins
capable que raymond barre un professeur
d'économie peut-être mais qui n'a jamais
eu de problèmes de fin de mois de gérer
le budget de la nation en tout cas si
elle avait un pouvoir de décision sur le
budget qu'elle travailleuses quelle mère
de famille accepterait de gaspiller
délibéré
des milliards le cinquième du budget de
l'état pour entretenir une armée et
construire des engins meurtriers qui
loin de nous protéger en cas de guerre
pour être tout juste faire de notre pays
un champ de bataille entre les deux
super grand si les femmes s'occupaient
du budget de la nation comme elle
s'occupe du budget de la maison elle
choisirait de consacrer l'argent des
impôts à tout ce qui fait la vie
quotidienne l'école les hôpitaux les
transports en commun la santé
l'environnement plutôt content j'ai deux
morts aucune femme ne sera cette fois ci
encore président de la république
mais toutes les femmes du peuple
pourront dire en votant pour ma
candidature au premier tour ciel sont
pour la guerre ou si elles sont pour que
l'on constate l'argent de l'état à des
oeuvres utile aujourd'hui les jeunes de
18 ans ont le droit de vote
et voilà tous les hommes politiques qui
cherchent à les flatter à les cages les
alors promettent monts et merveilles
mais les hommes de la majorité au
pouvoir n'ont pas honte de mentir aussi
effrontément car les jeunes il ne les
aime pas il s'en méfie le moindre
rassemblement de jeunes qu'il s'agisse
de concerts ou de motos attire les
policiers comme le miel attire les
mouches mais la société notre société
fermée injuste étouffante et hiérarchisé
crevant sous les fausses valeurs de
l'argent de la carrière de la bouffe et
de la propriété n'est fait ni pour les
femmes ni pour les jeunes ni d'ailleurs
pour tous ceux qui ne peuvent pas peser
sur les décisions des gouvernants c'est
ainsi que les hommes politiques ne re
découvre l'existence des retraités qu'au
moment des élections
mais le reste du temps ils ne veulent
pas savoir comment vivent les retraités
avec un budget qui devrait faire honte à
nos sociétés dites de consommation bien
sûr il y à de belles retraites il y a
même des gens qui cumulent une retraite
de l'armée ou de la gendarmerie avec un
emploi actifs
ce n'est pas évidemment de cela que je
parle
non je voudrais parler des autres ceux
qui sont le plus grand nombre il ne fait
pas bon être âgé au 20e siècle
même dans les pays dits riches le
gouvernement prétend avoir augmenté le
minimum
yet et avoir tiré de la misère des
centaines de milliers de personnes âgées
de la misère oui peut-être encore qu'il
ya chez les vieux les détresses cas chez
des personnes qui n'ont pas su ou pas pu
ou pas osé remplir les papiers
nécessaires pour toucher le fond de
solidarité par crainte par pudeur par
ignorance parfois pour ne pas nuire à
leurs enfants
nous en connaissons tous comme nous
connaissons tous de ces retraités qui
ont travaillé toute leur vie parfois
bien avant que les assurances sociales
existent et qui vivotent à peine avec
une retraite indécente car les retraités
sont les premiers touchés par
l'inflation par la dégradation des
services publics par la complication de
la vie administrative et il y a quelques
mois le gouvernement a osé prélevés sur
les retraites imposable 1% sur le régime
général 2% sur les complémentaires soit
disant pour combler le trou de la
sécurité sociale mais leur retraite
les travailleurs l'ont déjà payé au nord
de ne rien qu'il n'ait gagné sou à sou
dans une vie de travail
il s'agit là d'une mesure qui frappent
indistinctement quasiment tous l'air
toutes les retraites
les grosses comme les petites et c'est à
la fois injuste et indigne
et bien moi je dis les anciens ne
doivent rien à personne c'est nous tous
qui leur devons quelque chose c'est leur
travail leurs sacrifices qui ont permis
au pays de tourner dans une société -
david wise as juste il aurait encore
toute leur place dans la communauté
humaine comme des millions d'autres
femmes au travail
je n'ai pas besoin de statistiques pour
savoir ce que inflation et hausse des
prix veut dire et je sais aussi ce que
signifie pourtant de travailleurs
l'angoissent permanente de perdre son
travail sans espoir d'en retrouver ce
que signifie d'attendre en vain devant
les bureaux d'embauché sur les deux
millions de chômeurs d'aujourd'hui
combien d'entre eux at-on fait travail
et entêtant dans le passé quarante
heures 45 heure quand ce n'était pas 50
heures les hommes politiques disait
alors que c'était nécessaire que c'était
pour l'avenir mais qu'est ce que c'est
que cette société où l'on refuse
ailleurs le temps de vivre lorsque
l'économie va bien et où les condamne au
chômage
lorsque ça va mal en plus des chômeurs
il y à un million et demi de
travailleurs intérimaires étaient
intérimaires
un million et demi de travailleurs dont
le travail et les ressources dépendent
des seuls aléas de la production et du
marché et ils doivent en plus subir la
morgue des chefs assurés de trouver dix
postulants pour un salarié jetés à la
rue
bien sûr il y à la crise une crise
internationale
une crise de tout le système capitaliste
mais c'est un système fou celui qui nous
condamne à la pauvreté parce qu'on
produit trop c'est un système fou que
celui où des usines modernes reste fermé
où tant de bras tant de compétences sont
réduites à l'inactivité forcée alors que
des besoins non satisfaits sont immenses
on nous dit que chacun simplement sa
part dans un malheur commun mais les
travailleurs et tous ceux qui souffrent
réellement de la crise n'y sont pour
rien dans la situation économique
catastrophique ce ne sont pas eux qui
dirigent l'économie et ce ne sont pas
eux qui l'emmenait à la faillite
alors il n'y a pas de raison qu'ils
paient pour messieurs peugeot gillet
riboud ambroise - enfin michelin ou
d'autres il n'y a pas de raison pour
qu'il paie pour un régime dont un ne
tire aucun profit
quand les affaires allaient bien les
travailleurs n'ont pas touché plus que
leur salaire mais les grandes
entreprises ont multiplié leurs profits
et leurs capitaux et aujourd'hui
pourtant ce sont les grandes entreprises
et leurs capitaux que l'état protège au
il y en a qui n'ont même pas besoin de
cette protection
savez vous que deux des plus importants
de compagnies pétrolières françaises en
une année en 79 en pleine crise ont
multiplié leurs profits l'une par trois
l'autre par quatre qui parmi ceux qui ne
vivent que de leur travail peut en dire
autant les affaires d'autres grandes
entreprises vont plus mal et bien avec
l'argent pris dans notre poche l'état de
leur a donné de quoi continuer à faire
des bénéfices ces grosses entreprises
celle de la sidérurgie par exemple qui
ont reçu cet argent
ont-elles au moins créer des emplois non
pas un seul
elles ont tout compris mais diminué
or ses effectifs la rationalisation de
la production comme ils disent
l'augmentation de la productivité que
certaines de ces entreprises ont payé
avec l'argent de l'état avec notre
argent at elle au moins atténuer la
crise non c'est même le contraire qui se
passe
car toutes les grosses entreprises de
par le monde les américaines comme les
allemandes et japonaises comme les
italiennes ont toutes augmenté leur
productivité en même temps et pour les
mêmes raisons mais le nombre de clients
susceptibles d'acheter n'a pas augmenté
alors plus les grandes entreprises
produisent d'automobiles ou d'acier et
plus la guerre entre économique entre
elles et féroce l'état protège le
capital des grandes entreprises mais pas
le travail et le salaire de l'ouvrier
pourtant la balance n'est pas égal pour
les travailleurs il s'agit de leur
gagne-pain de leur vie alors il faut que
les capitaux servent à garantir
lorsque les affaires ne vont pas bien le
niveau de vie des travailleurs qui les
ont produits syli a crise c'est aux
banquiers aux grandes entreprises de
payer ni aux travailleurs ni aux paysans
ni aux petits commerçants non plus aux
paysans on avait dix équipes et vous me
des remises et vos installations
emprunter il faut que vous soyez
concurrentiel pour le marché commun
alors certains se sont équipés en
s'endettant et en tombant souvent sous
la dépendance des banques et des grosses
sociétés de l'agroalimentaire tandis que
les autres faute de moyens ont dû
quitter la terre parfois pour devenir
directement chômeurs en ville mais à
quoi donc a servi que les paysans
s'équipent pour être plus productif une
bonne récolte devrait se traduire par
une amélioration et pour les
consommateurs et pour les petits paysans
mais c'est exactement le contraire qui
se passe
les prix à la consommation ne baisse pas
par contre les paysans n'arrivent pas à
vendre leurs produits
parce que les réseaux de distribution ne
les achète plus pour les capitalistes de
la distribution il est plus rentable de
commercialiser moins mais plus cher il y
a toujours une différence considérable
entre les prix payés aux paysans et les
prix à la consommation
mais le petit détaillant qui amène la
marchandise près du consommateur fait au
moins un travail utile
tout le monde ne peut pas se déplacer
jusqu'aux grandes surfaces
et celle-ci ne vendent moins cher que
parce qu'elles font déplacer des
consommateurs tant qu'ils pourront payer
l'essence pour se déplacer en voiture
mais leurs bénéfices sont en réalité
bien supérieur par rapport au travail
fourni et même aux capitaux investis à
ceux des petits commerçants et bien
pourquoi ne pas imposer à ces sociétés
qui tout au long de l'année prélèvent
leur profit à la fois sur les pays n'en
est sûre les consommateurs de vente sans
bénéfices les produits agricoles
excédentaire au moment des récoltes
pourquoi ne pas imposer aux grandes
sociétés de distribution de transporter
à prix coûtant sinon gratuitement les
excédents au moment des récoltes de
façon ce que les agriculteurs est une
juste rétribution et que les
consommateurs profitent de l'abondance
la droite au pouvoir pour conserver ou
pour gagner des voix aux élections a
libéré les prix en autorisant les
commerçants à prélever sur les
consommateurs
de quoi se protéger contre l'inflation
seulement à quoi bon cette liberté même
pour les petits commerçants si demain la
crise et le chômage font qu'ils n'ont
plus de clients à qui vendre alors je
dis que le sort des petits commerçants
est lié à celui des ouvriers des
employés et que les travailleurs et en
particulier les personnes âgées n'ont
rien à gagner à ce que les petits
commerces près de chez eux disparaissent
et puis je veux dénoncer ce que coûte
aux classes laborieuses qui paye
l'essentiel des impôts l'école salle
dépenses improductives de l'état à
commencer par le budget militaire
ils sont là tous les politiciens des
grands partis à chipoter pour savoir où
trouver les 12 ou les 19 ou les 20
milliards pour leurs plans respectifs
pour relancer l'économie
aussi insuffisant et mensongers l'un que
l'autre
mais ni la droite ni mitterrand ni
marchait ne parle de prélever cet argent
sur le budget colossal de l'armée qui
pendant ce temps englouti en une seule
année
cinq fois plus soit 104 milliards de
francs actuels pourtant la moitié de ce
budget sert exclusivement à payer les
officiers les militaires de carrière et
ce qu'ils appellent leurs dépenses de
fonctionnement pour défendre le pays
allons donc la seule fois en 60 ans ou
le ps
réellement attaquée en juin 1940 à quoi
ont-ils donc services et professionnels
de la guerre à rien et depuis on les a
vus à l'oeuvre en indochine en algérie
en afrique c'est à dire à des milliers
de kilomètres du territoire national
pour mener des guerres qui n'avait rien
à voir avec les intérêts de la
population française guerre qu'ils ont
d'ailleurs perdu car ils avaient en face
d'eux des peuples qui se battent est
réellement pour se défendre
voyez la marine nationale sont seuls ou
fait d'armes depuis des années a été de
prendre d'assaut l'été dernier au large
d'antifer
les bateaux des marins pêcheurs en grève
alors franchement ces gens là
faut-il les payer très cher année après
année pour intervenir contre le pop ou
contre la démocratie
le jour où justement un parlement où un
président élu ne lui convient pas comme
l'armée a tenté de le faire il ya peu en
espagne et comme on vient seulement de
l'apprendre
l'armée avait envisagé de le faire
également en angleterre il y a dix ans
pour renverser un gouvernement
travailliste travailleuses travailleurs
je suis avant tout une candidate de
gauche et mon combat est avant tout
dirigée contre les hommes de la droite
qui sont les candidats des exploiteurs
et des riches mais je veux offrir un
autre visage de la gauche que celui qu
en donne marchais mitterrand je veux
présente pour qu'au moins quelqu'un dise
que quel que soit le candidat qui sera
élu
la crise l'inflation le chômage
continueront et que nous tous
ouvriers employés retraités artisans
petits commerçants paysans tous ceux qui
vivent de leur travail sans exploiter
personnes
nous saurons si nous nous laissons faire
les sacrifiés de la crise comme par
mitterrand comme par giscard sacrifiées
aux intérêts des grandes sociétés
car les grandes entreprises et les
banques chercheront inévitablement avec
l'aide de l'état à réduire les classes
populaires à la portion congrue
alors ce qui est important pour l'avenir
bien au delà de la personne de celui qui
sera élu c'est que les classes
populaires soient côte à côte
là où ça compte vraiment dans la lutte
mais je dis aussi que ces élections
doivent être
- l'occasion de lancer un avertissement
pour dire aux politiciens de droite
comme à ceux de la gauche que ni les
ouvriers ou les employés ni les paysans
ou les artisans n'accepterons plus qu'on
leur manque encore et toujours
je me présente pour que les électeurs
puissent condamner la politique de la
droite
votez pour ma candidature se sera voté
contre giscard et chirac
incontestablement à gauche mais ce sera
aussi un vote de défiance envers les
dirigeants de la gauche qui sont les
faux amis des travailleurs pour qu'ils
sachent qu'on ne peut pas impunément
trahir les espérances des travailleurs
pour que marché sachent qu'on ne peut
pas impunément se moquer des
travailleurs en criant vive mitterrand
un jour et abat mitterrand le lendemain
pour que mitterrand sache que les
travailleurs n'accepterons pas qu'il
gouverne à droite après avoir été élu
avec les voix de la gauche
je ne pense pas que mitterrand fera
mieux que giscard mais je ne me présente
pas pour faire obstacle à son élection
car je suis solidaire des millions de
travailleurs et d'électeurs de gauche
qui souhaite que giscard soient battus
et que mitterrand l'emportent au
deuxième tour et je dis que si les
travailleurs à tort ou à raison préfère
mitterrand il faut faire l'expérience de
mitterrand mais au premier tour il faut
que tous ceux qui sont contre la droite
mais qui ne font pas confiance aux
dirigeants de la gauche dès ce qu'il
pense en votant pour ma candidature
ce sera aussi la meilleure manière nous
montrer aux industriels et aux banquiers
que quel que soit l'homme qui sera élu
au deuxième tour
ils ne devront pas compter sur
l'attractivité de la population
laborieuse de leur montrer qu'ils
existent parmi les travailleurs des
villes comme parmi des travailleurs des
champs des centaines de milliers
d'hommes et de femmes qui ne sont pas
résignés vous tous qui appartenait au
grand pope des travailleurs le 26 avril
voter arlette laguillier ce sera un
moyen pour vous ne montrez que vous
n'êtes pas prêt à être les victimes
consentantes de la crise que vous
n'acceptez pas que vos votes ne servent
qu à arbitrer les rivalités entre les
grands partis de gauche
que vous ne vous contenterez pas de
discours et de promesses travailleuses
travailleurs
je vous demande de voter au premier tour
pour une femme
une travailleuse pour faire respecter
toute la population laborieuse
[Musique]